well it's really a day that many people
have been waiting for everyone now
16 and older can get the vaccine we also
hit another milestone
more than a million doses have been
administered now in clark county
and more than 360 thousand are fully
vaccinated
sally jaramillo visited unlv which is a
location that was pretty busy today
especially for those
teenagers and those in their 20s it's
terrific that
finally we have opened up to the whole
public michael gardner is the ceo and
president at the unlv school of medicine
he says it's a good feeling that
everyone can now get vaccinated
twenty two hundred people were scheduled
for monday we'll probably do over two
thousand
zoe mealy is an eighteen-year-old unlv
student she was worried about long
lines with everyone eligible i thought
it was going to take me forever but
actually i got
through pretty quick it was not bad at
all i'm actually really afraid of
needles
i sat there the guy talked me through it
and it was it was quick and painless
miley says she has the necessary
vaccines throughout her life
and wants to do her part to remain
healthy just like sean ake
who moved from hawaii he thought he'd
had to wait until summer
but i felt safe throughout the whole
process and feeling good right now his
message to those not convinced to get
the vaccine right away
i would still encourage the younger
people especially 16 and up to get it
because you know
it's not only for you but to keep our
elders safe as well
we can handle the capacity we're excited
about it sally jaramillo 8 news now